how's bam doing by the way i mean
i think not not good
he's hanging in there
it's uh it's tough man i wish that uh
you know like when he had his real like
[ __ ] meltdown and he's
coming up with his own alphabet and he's
[ __ ] like all over tmz and he's
getting arrested left and right
i was thinking yes you know he's he's
wondering who's that
you know he's on the bottom he he's
where i was at this is what it takes yes
you know we're gonna now he's gonna
[ __ ] do it like trying
and he's just still you know like i feel
like
he he reached that because that was the
problem i saw for the longest time
and and for what i'm so grateful for
myself which is that
i got so [ __ ] bad it had to stop you
know
like like there's only one way to go
there was no there was nothing [ __ ]
okay
about what i was up to at the end of my
run with drugs now
and that was but what's strange me too
for for you i mean it helped a lot of
people so thank god but
that's documented too oh my god i've
seen that
it's [ __ ] it's heartbreaking man yeah
and what's weird is johnny knoxville
goes in and because you guys are such
boys
like you can tell like johnny knoxville
god bless him has like a switch where
he's like
you know this isn't this isn't cool man
like we're not here
to film and you know no one's doing that
[ __ ] we're here to help
that's why we're [ __ ] here yeah for
sure and uh
you know i i i say it all the time like
you know we identify as alcoholics and
addicts it's like part of our deal
in recovery and uh i always say that you
know i'm an alcoholic i'm an addict and
i'm just
grateful that i suffer from alcoholism
and addiction
so [ __ ] bad that i don't have to
wonder
if i belong in this program of recovery
yeah you know
i don't have to the right spot that's
the worst it's the worst situation
you could be in in my view is to just
have alcoholism
just kind of like just suffer from
addiction just enough
the greater that that like that it's not
so bad that it absolutely has to stop
but it's just bad enough that it can
[ __ ] up your
everything that you do just bad enough
that you can just makes make
poor decisions you can just waste a ton
of time
you can just not be motivated not
accomplish anything
so it's just bad enough to [ __ ] up your
life so that the
years turn into decades just slipping
through your fingers
you know where in my case it was so
[ __ ] bad i had so clear-cut i
had to get sober and then once i got
sober it's like oh wait a second now i'm
not wasting a lot of time
getting loaded so i can be going in the
wrong direction making messes and
but you have to be kind of a north star
kind of you know
uh an example for bam and these other
attitudes right
like you should be a north star because
like look at stevie he's [ __ ]
crushing it man like you guys could do
this i wish
and i don't know what it says about me
but some of my best friends are all
addicts
you know they're recovering you know
i mean dude it's it's the way to be like
the thing like alcoholism and addiction
is the only disease
where when
when you you get it you fight after once
you
treat the disease any other disease you
treat it
and your best hope is to get back to as
good as you were before you got it
but alcoholism and addiction when you
treat that
you actually become an improved version
of yourself than you were before
no other disease do you still struggle
with this stupo i mean
but like you don't think because you
when you're when you're because
being on tour like being the economy
clubs like to be honest
i didn't drink or do nicotine or
anything before i started doing stand up
then i was around the scene and then
rogan was like oh i take a shot before
every set
uh and it was like a big night at the
comedy story he's like have a shot with
me like dude i
i need all my wits when i'm up there
he's like i'm telling you i've been
doing some long time
this a real action like all right i'll
do it settle my life
dude off to the races now now you know
i'm drinking
every set i have my own whiskey coming
out you know what i'm saying so it's
like
it's like alcohol and drugs kind of go
hand in hand a little bit with what we
do
you know because you're every club like
that's how they make their nut too
yeah okay sure plus the i'm the sober
guy and my
my crowd drinks like more than anybody's
crowd
you take pictures with every single
person i remember that you took that's
so great bro
every single person i can't believe you
genuinely that's unbelievable yeah
i've always seen that like i i feel like
it's self-serving if i can send
everybody possible home with a photo
then they're going to post on their
social media they're going tell other
friends i had a great time at my show
it's like grassroots promotion i think
that really helped me
you know um but you don't struggle with
that with it being in the club stuff
like that at all
i don't i don't spend a lot of time like
i can't i don't want to be like cavalier
and and overconfident and say i don't i
don't think about you know
drinking but like really i might travel
with the sober guy
you know my dude that i traveled you're
not around your fiance's obviously sober
she's just never had an issue you know
she
she's never gotten loaded around me she
doesn't get loaded you know yeah she'll
smoke weed
sometimes but never around me yeah and
she's not an issue for her but uh
she so it's not um i i
i just kind of am i'm plugged in with
like the
the recovery community i don't feel that
i'm like um
like at risk of of getting loaded
because
like i'm sort of i am vigilant about
the you know whatever the program um but
with that said you'll hear people who
are clean and sober
those they say something that's pretty
like legitimately terrifying
which is that uh i never
suffered from alcoholism until i got
sober
because if you think about it the
disease has not really got anything to
do with
drinking the drink like the disease is
this underlying
sense of of uh like
discontent restless irritable content
something yeah so you're drinking to you
the actual
alcohol is is a symptom of the of the
disease you know like it's actually
you could even go one step further the
alcohol is the
the solution that's the your medicine
yeah for the disease
and then all of a sudden the medicine
turns on you and everything that drove
you to drink is still
you know you take away the alcohol and
now you're actually suffering
you got to deal with it yeah that's why
it's so important to have the community
of recovery you know that's why
did you go to a therapist i'm still or
no
i've had people yet because after the
[ __ ] uh drugs and i got sober with
drugs and alcohol
and uh you know i was a couple years
sober and and uh
started the comedy tour and the thing
about taking photos with every single
audience member possible
like uh this is you know still to this
day
before i get off stage i i will not go
anywhere
or do anything until i take a photo with
every single one of you guys
the whole the whole audience like you
know basically
for the most part forms a line oh yeah
you know i formed the line i could
and and for the first the first however
many years
of my comedy tour that meet and greet
was a glorified [ __ ] audition
to figure out who i was going to act out
with sexually that night
you know like straight up and uh
that's what that's what it is it just
dawned on me what you do
i'm sorry i was a little late but i got
it
auditioned and that's another addiction
like people don't want to talk about
them but that might be the worst
addiction because it's like
you don't realize it but it's like it's
totally another addiction
if you think about like what's taken
down like the most
like uh successful people like destroyed
myself
you know that sex is by far more
destructive
by far that then drugs now cause i think
so how'd you deal with that the way that
it went down
i was like at this point i want to say
uh i was like 38
39 and i i remember going to
um going to atlanta the punch line where
the
the club owner is chris depeta and uh
you know my act at that time was all
about just like
the groupie sex like the triple blow job
the you know
like this it was just super blue and and
and i remember after my show chris
christopher was like man what's like
what are you doing dude what are you
doing with your comment
yeah he's like he's like he's like sure
you might be getting away with it now oh
it's getting my dick sucked but do you
really wanna you know you're getting to
an
age where like is that really what you
want
like you're getting it's just kind of
creepy really you know like
and and and the thing was that that was
my lifestyle you know
and i was like [ __ ] he's right and so
the way that
the way that it unfolded i started to
think okay i'm 38 like
i like i'm almost 40. do i really like
do i want to be living this lifestyle
you know what i'm going to be that guy
i had do i had this awful joke where i
said you know
like uh how you know i'm
gonna be 40 like do i you know i have to
ask myself do i want to be
50 and physically falling apart
and trying to hump everything that moves
it's not so
and i just recognized that this wasn't
the way to be happy
let me ask you this devo too when you're
doing those meet and greets and at the
time i mean it's well known i'm not
saying anything the viewers don't or
listeners don't know but you you there's
time you're dating kat von d
which was a super public relationship
sure
it's not like if you were flirting with
girls like people are aware that you
have this
famous girlfriend right now and at the
time you guys were like you're like a
power couple yeah which is awkward too
you know that that came later it was at
like at the end of
2015 the cat and i got in this
fairly brief relationship um during 2013
i uh i i started out by saying look you
know
i i subscribed to the idea that future
happened being really happy is
contingent on me learning how to have a
healthy relationship
you know like i just like to have a life
partner to not
just with all the [ __ ] time wasted
chasing chicks
it's such a distraction it's such a
distraction such a time
waster there's just all kinds of
attendant stress
and then it's like you know you see when
you're ghosting chicks and you feel like
the [ __ ] worst piece of [ __ ]
it's just the word you know there's
everything about it was just [ __ ]
awful and i was like this isn't this
isn't the way
so i i made a conscious decision i
promised myself
like i'm i'm not gonna [ __ ] fool
around with chicks on the rim and stop
acting out on the road i'm just thinking
you know like i'm just gonna like
address my
you know my behavior and yeah i couldn't
[ __ ] do it
this is like the you know i identified
the
it's just a full addiction i broke my
promise every trip
i'd come back and i'd be like [ __ ] i did
it again i would say it's the toughest
thing in the world
yeah people i don't think people
understand but that would be one of the
toughest addictions
that was when i got into therapy yeah
that was when i got into therapy and a
therapy
a therapist that uh specialized in in
sexual addiction and uh you know
did she have you texting me he was a
dude
on the road and it just turned in it it
just
flowed out it became comedy it it flowed
out
yes my my whole act went from like
like i i you know i never stapled my
ball sack
to my leg for the joy of it yeah i did
it to get laid
you know like i wanted to get [ __ ] like
[ __ ] and
and then when jackass came out and all
of a sudden this happens
you know like uh it was that was my act
and then it turned into like but i don't
want to be this way so i tried to stop
and like
you know i said i'm not going to float
around with any chicks and then
the next trip i go on there i am in in
uh
the titty bars
dude i was minding my own [ __ ]
business and
and this is a completely true story too
minding my own business
this this dancer and uh
she comes running over just bee lines it
for me she's just
like she comes hauling us over and
swivels around sticks her butt in my
face
i look at it and she had literally
my autograph tattooed on her butt cheek
what can you say how am i supposed to
turn down a piece of ass with my name on
it
for you when i get off stage at the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song